un choc en inde districts voisins
gargenville deux équipes dans le top 3
de la division s'affronter ce dimanche
17 novembre sur le terrain de
voisins-le-bretonneux après une phase
d'observation la première période et
finalement remporté par les visiteurs
car janvier marquent deux buts en contre
2 à 0 à la mi-temps première mi temps
compliquée on a du mal à mettre en place
notre notre bloc équipe kindle qui a
fait notre force depuis le début de
saison du comprend des on est un peu
trop trop loin les uns des autres et on
prend des contres attaques en deuxième
période voisin poussent pour revenir au
score mais ce sont finalement les
joueurs de gargenville qui creuse
l'écart avec un troisième but 3 0 ce
sera le score final
seconde mi temps c'était mieux on voit
on a commencé à rentrer dans notre
compte malheureusement ça faisait 45
minutes que moi j'avais débuté mais bon
c'était c'était beaucoup mieux
après on a un peu manqué d'efficacité on
prend un but dans les arrêts de jeu un
peu anecdotique après cette rencontre
gargenville prend le large en tête du
classement avec cinq points d'avancé sur
le second
de son côté voisin pointe à la troisième
place et nourrit encore de grandes
ambitions pour cette saison notre
objectif finir alors on va dire dans les
quatre premiers les quatre premiers du
championnat après faire le bilan en mars
et pas se mettre de pression on prend
les matches les uns après les autres
continuez on débute dans cette division
donc il n'ya pas aucune pression
particulière
on prend du plaisir et on apprend on
progresse ensemble pour rebondir voisins
le bretonneux tentera de s'imposer sur
le terrain de bois d'arcy le dimanche 24
novembre
de son côté gargenville se rendra sur le
terrain de sartrouville